foreign
ever been loved by anyone I want to know
if it's too late to find that what makes
you think you've never been loved I know
you know when you left I'm assuming
because I have not ever thought that
except for my children
[Music]
what's up this is John with the Dr John
deloney show
I'm so grateful that you are hanging out
with us giving us your most precious
resource your time you got so much other
stuff you got to be doing so many other
voices competing for your attention
those clothes in your closet are saying
why don't you clean me up and those
clothes and laundry saying why don't you
wash me are you lazy and the dishes are
like hey why don't you and you're
spending your time with us and the tires
are like why won't you rotate me do you
not want to be alive and all of our
stuff everything is just yelling at you
and you chose to sit down with us and
I'm super super grateful if you want to
be on the show I would love to have you
on
um I may not be able to give you much
wisdom but I'd love to have you uh hang
out for a little while go to John
deloney.com ask a-s-k
um or give me a buzz at 1-844-693-3291
um if you have some good news to report
like hey me and my wife have started uh
a year ago we started listening to the
show together we started talking we
changed the way we communicate and hear
some some success stories that would be
fantastic if you would
um call in and share them or uh go to
John deloney.com ask that would be
fantastic hey I'm can I say yes I'm
going to
um
you have been getting a ton of success
stories no kidding yes as of yesterday I
had well over 20. wow okay that's cool
so we're going to be talking about those
soon but I just wanted people to say to
thank you to people way to go but
there's some great stuff in there
there's good stuff yeah really is Ah
that's awesome
um and speaking of saying nice things
don't forget your five star reviews and
please hit the Subscribe button please
please please please all right let's go
to Maggie in Columbia South Carolina
what's up Maggie
hi Dr John thanks for having me of
course thank you I'll be in Columbia
South Carolina in a few weeks
oh awesome yeah it's a great City my
husband and I are Avid listeners of a
show and we appreciate all you do well
I'm really grateful for you thank you so
much what's up how can I help
so my question is how do I begin
asserting myself in my marriage when
I've been dismissive of myself and my
needs for most of my life and I can
provide background yeah of course tell
me more
okay so my parents divorced when I was
young my dad chose to leave his role in
my life I had turned a disordered eating
and spent High School hiding and eating
disorder
um moving away to college my disordered
eating became crippling and I turned to
sex to satisfy my loneliness
which led to a lot of unwanted sexual
trauma and I didn't have any hope and
had considered taking my life until I
met my husband now but he was my
boyfriend at the time and so fast
forward 10 years with extensive therapy
my husband and I now have two young kids
and I've had postpartum depression with
both
so I'm at a point right now in my
marriage where I no longer want to take
a back seat
back seat I want to be an equal and have
my needs heard and my boundaries
acknowledged it's just been hard for me
because
with my whole background I'm so used to
just putting everyone else before myself
and I've spent a lot of time being
lonely yeah
that's you you articulated that really
really well
um how often have you said those things
out loud in a row like that
so this is this is not a story that
you've told over and over again this is
a story that you are beginning to feel
strong enough to begin to put out into
the universe is that fair
that's fair okay who when you were a
little kid where did where did you learn
that your job was to take care of
everybody else
that lack of control in your world that
that was the way you started trying to
grab onto it
well my dad left and had just decided
that he didn't want to participate
anymore
um what did I do what did they do to
your mom
um crushed her yeah
yeah we and my sister and I absorbed
that tell me about that
um
so my mom got remarried pretty quick
after my parents split but she remarried
someone similar to my dad and she was
always the person taking care of my dad
or my stepdad so we had just kind of
learned like okay we take care of other
people and I grew up in a really passive
aggressive home
um so it was kind of like you have these
but you don't talk about them but then
you let them out and kind of a bizarre
way
yeah passive aggressive homes are like
mind reader homes and they make people
crazy yeah yeah um which is why an
eating disorder was so great because I
could control
everything well you can yeah yes yes and
so you say you hit it
um yeah
uh tell me about that
yeah so I kind of had heard
how old is to give Clarity so I had
um
or probably I'm in recovery now but had
started with anorexia which was not easy
to hide because you start losing a lot
of weight and then moved into being
bulimic for a long time which was easier
to hide because you tend to remain the
same weight
um
so that was kind of easier to hide I was
actually very high achieving in
academics and did really well so I would
kind of come and go for my house as I
needed and that's not uncommon because
that was another way you got people off
your back
absolutely I'm gonna I'm gonna make all
I'm gonna check all of the boxes that
you need to leave me alone
yes
and because I want to paint a picture
for you how this dance works okay
there is a
we always talk about the divorce like
dad walks out on us
but from a trauma perspective especially
for young kids we often forget the two
or three or four years before that
that Mom and Dad's relationship would
have been a mess
and that chaos would have ricocheted
through all the little kids in the house
through every all the relational
interactions in the house so at a really
young age
you start feeling how electric
everything is and how you don't want to
make mom mad because she was just crying
because like there's not just a divorce
is rarely just instantaneous right and
so then that happens
and your little girl wondering what was
so bad about you that dad left and then
Mom rushes to fill that Gap with some
knucklehead some other guy and you're
still you're still wondering where's mom
what about us are we not good enough
right she haven't seen so the whole
dance happens but then a weird thing
happens
you find safety when you're alone
and your body craves it and so you start
grabbing ways to control and you end up
realizing you you found some currency
with your body I can actually connect
with people and keep them at arm's
length at the same time by by Sleeping
with people that I'm not super invested
with
foreign
how your body plays both sides of that
equation until it falls in on itself
yes it actually it actually works for a
while right just like alcohol Just Like
Cocaine like it all works for a while it
works for a while yes
um what tell me what it was about this
guy you were dating amidst all of this
that suddenly you said he's different
yeah so he um like I said he's my
husband now we actually listen to her
show together
um he it was interesting right he just
wasn't selfish he was just more
interested about me as a person and
trying to meet my needs and just kind of
taking whatever he could get
and that was probably the first time
anyone's really done that for me
um and nothing about your past and I'm
just not talking sexually but I'm
talking about your past just the
challenges you've had that didn't scare
him off
eventually that had come out
um and we were able to work through that
okay
and he didn't leave and that was kind of
another thing it was like oh I'm just
sharing more and more about myself
um that I think is just going to cause
you to leave like other people have okay
and you're still here so fast forward to
right now what is it about this season
or what needs are not being met are you
not vocalizing or are you not feeling
like you're an equal part of your home
um
we've have I know I mentioned we have
two young kids and having postpartum
depression with both the first time I
went through it I felt very lonely and
it kind of took me back to this place of
like
um
I guess it kind of just took me back
um you know I felt like I was
I know my husband's not here to find
himself but you know Hey listen I've
I've had two kids and I did not do it
well either time so okay okay
it's just you know
um you know why don't you want him and
why are you so sad and this is what
you've always wanted
um and so it just became one of those
things where I started hiding again
right hmm
I'm so sorry you know then we have my
son and he grows up and well he's not
grown he's the woken but we
um you know kind of go back and forth
with trying to raise him and then I got
pregnant with my daughter and so now all
of these fears of abandonments are
coming back and like I'm not enough
um each time there's been a huge life
event like getting married having my son
and then having my daughter it feels
like everything from my past bubbles
back up right and and I want you to
maybe the first time in your life stop
stop the civil war between you and your
body
it's it's trying to take care of you the
best it can
and it knows this story
where kid number two comes in Dead
Leaves
so it it knows that story and so it's
just trying to remind to get your
attention to remind you as loud as
possible hey this is what's coming even
though it's not right
when mom probably heard
um or stepdad heard a full narrative
about what you were experiencing in
middle school they probably told you
that it was dumb or stop talking or you
should just leave or we're tired stop
Hush Hush go go go go we're in the
middle of something
and so you learned at a young age that
stories about you
turn people away from you
and so over time your body really went
to war with you and you started telling
somebody that you had a vested interest
in about you the truth about you some of
the experiences that you you've had
and so all along the way your body's
trying to be a friend in this deal and
trying to help you out
it's just now that those things that
used to keep you alive and keep you safe
are now
making him making you crazy and there's
nothing like having a kid like feeling
like having your and again nobody needs
another six foot two white male telling
women how their bodies work right but
like there's
nothing to make you feel less Con in
control than having a baby right your
body's not yours anymore
it's like a it's like a an RV for a a
kid
and yeah yep it kind of does its own
things and it grows and it's weird and
it stretches and it's not yours knowing
your kid's born you're a jungle gym and
a food dispenser and like and then a
couple of months in husband comes
Pawling back at you like hey and all of
a sudden whoosh your body remembers when
we didn't have control
and remember when we kept everyone at
arm's length so that we could protect
ourselves and we did protect ourselves
but we went crazy because we were
isolated alone
and you see that weird figure eight
dance that just happens over and over
and over again
yes
so you are not gonna like my answer on
where to go from here
you won't
um
you are going this is not a to be fully
present to start speaking your needs out
loud to say things that you want to to
be heard in your home from your kids
from yourself from your husband from
your community
there's not a checklist that you can do
by yourself
what you're going to have to do is
practice relational safety which means
you're going to have to regularly get
with people
who are not your husband and practice
saying things out loud and then feeling
your body when it feels completely and
totally exposed
and heading into that storm not away
from it like you've done for your entire
life
okay you cannot and hear me say this and
I'm saying it because I love you you
cannot do this part by yourself
here's why the pressure your body will
feel
your your autonomic nervous system won't
allow it the pressure your body will
exert on you to not fully Express how
you feel to your husband because he
might leave that story is so woven into
the fabric of your body
that you're going to always hedge your
bets and then you're going to hate
yourself for hedging your bets and then
your body's got a whole system of
behaviors to take care of you when you
hate yourself like disordered eating
like
um finding yourself by by sleeping
around like whatever behaviors and then
you're just going to invent new ones you
know what I mean like working 90 hours a
week or
um
see there you go and most of us we don't
realize it we just go through our lives
going from anxiety to OCD to Addiction
in this Loop and we just pass we just
finally kick addictions and kick
addictions until we find one that the
world rewards us for and usually that's
codependency on a relationship or
working a lot
and eventually the work will go to
alcohol almost or you're going to find
somebody at work that's going to make
you feel alive again because you're so
distant and you're going to end up
doing something that you can't take back
relationally with your husband
is that fair
yeah so I will tell you one thing you
can do by yourself well so let me back
up
um
everything you've been told about your
body
up until now that
um
it's for somebody else's enjoyment
you're not in control all those things
has led you to this story that your body
can't be trusted
and think about this for a second this
is hard when I'm going to say out loud
okay is that cool
yes yep
your body told you you can't even be
happy with your kids
yeah
your body told you you can't even tell
when you look good and when you don't
your body told you we have one value
and that is getting that guy off
or finding connection with fill in the
way so your body has been trying to take
care of you for so long and you've got
to make peace with the fact that your
body's not telling you the truth anymore
and that's a scary realization and also
a super freeing realization
nodding okay okay so we're gonna get
some friends whether that's a group
whether it's a woman's group whether
that's a counselor
um it may be time for a new therapist I
would recommend a group because you are
probably
um just by talking to you you are
brilliant enough to work work your way
and I've I've just spent my whole career
working with especially young women with
eating disorders uh disorder eating and
they are Masters at controlling a
conversation
right
yep some of the best I've ever
encountered ever and I was a dean of
students at a law school for five years
so it's they're they can't hold a candle
so
um I recommend getting in a with a group
or getting three or four women that are
your friends and tell them that some
idiot on a podcast or on YouTube told
you that you've got to have three or
four people in your life that know
everything all the things
foreign
terrifying and insane
this will only be healed relationally
once your body begins to learn that it's
okay to say things out loud then you can
enter into that space with your husband
that says I need help around here or I
know you love me and when you ask me
why I can't be happy with our kids
my body leaves I'm out
and right now saying those words out
loud are terrifying right
yeah here's this here's one thing you
can do by yourself okay I want it's
remember those little t-shirts I don't
know how old you are but there used to
be t-shirts called mind the gap and
I always thought it was making fun of
the store
um is that what it was for Kelly what
was it for Kelly no they're for it's
British when you get on the um
the underground oh behind the Gap
because they when you get on the
Underground they tell you that so don't
step in the in between the the platform
and the the car I always thought Mine
The Gap was making fun of the store that
was telling you what to wear and whatnot
I guess I missed that so I'm going to
tell you to mine the Gap and here's what
I mean by that
I want you to begin to look for and
probably get a journal and write it down
or use the notes app on your phone I
want you to start looking for places
in moments in your day
when your body starts to run off on you
and just get some space between it taken
off on you and what just happened
so your husband walks in the door and
all of a sudden you start to feel the
need to leave the room
pause right there before you leave and
just ask yourself
what are you trying to protect me from
and it's really a curiosity it's not a
it's not we're not mad I'm not angry I'm
just asking my body like what did you
find here that was scary
or when your kid comes in and you start
to push him away
ask yourself
what is it about my baby that I'm trying
to push away right now is it am I over
stimulated is his breath really weird
has he not changed his diaper and
actually I need help from Dad and I
haven't said it out loud and he's too
clueless to even pay attention like what
is it that is causing my hand to rise up
and push my baby away
and again it's a curious thing it's not
that you're a bad mom because you're
clearly not it's just your body's got
some wired stuff wired into it and we're
just going to get to the bottom of what
it's trying to protect you from
my guess is it's going to try to protect
you from people that you love getting
too close because if they find out about
you they're going to leave again
okay so mind the gap begin to practice
that space I still have to do that all
the time too that's a practice I think
most of us will in go do the rest for
the rest of our lives
um
but before the day's over I want you to
find a group
find some some friends some women that
you will make a regular connection with
on a calendar you won't miss and you are
going to practice saying things out loud
and feeling completely and totally
exposed
without the pressure of your body
thinking your husband's gonna leave when
he finds out
or that your kids are going to fill in
the blank whatever they're gonna they're
gonna take off on you
hang on the line here's what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna send you
um own your past change your future the
book I want you to read through it in
fact I'm gonna send you two copies I
want you to read one and your husband to
read one also I'm gonna send you both of
the questions for humans couples cards
here's what I want you to do with those
just practice having a conversation with
your husband and these are no pressure
there's no they're just slow like uh
it's not bass fishing where you're
pulling a lure back all the time this is
catfish and you're still not there
letting it sit these are low impact
questions you'll go to dinner do five
cards ten cards and you're just getting
two quote unquote know each other a
little bit better but the whole time
what you're really doing is practicing
telling your husband things about you
catching your body when it starts to
take off
and reminding yourself that you're safe
you're safe you're safe
so grateful for you Maggie so grateful
for you we'll be right back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from this episode sponsor betterhelp hey
look there's a lot of things we don't
get to choose on this wild ride called
life right the neighbor's kid learning
to play Trombone weird things trending
on the tick tocks or whatever that is we
don't get to choose the weather but when
you realize how much you do have a
choice in it's so empowering check this
out you get to decide who you want to be
I get to ask myself the question who do
I want to be you get to choose who
speaks into your life and you get to
choose to pursue meaningful
relationships this is life-changing
stuff but I'll be honest it's not easy
these are new skills that we all have to
learn and therapy is a great place to
practice these new skills and that's why
I love better help better help is
Affordable online therapy that can match
you with a therapist quickly and it lets
you switch any time to make sure it's
the right fit and just like in-person
therapy it can help equip you with the
tools you need to work towards being who
you want to be because you don't just
have to let life happen to you you can
take it head on so visit betterhelp.com
deloney today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right let's go to uh
in detone in Dallas Texas what's up Anne
hey Dr John how are you I'm good
beautiful how are you
um I'm okay I've been better otherwise I
wouldn't be calling you
one day and somebody's gonna call the
show and just be like I'm doing awesome
one day one day I'll do that one day in
a year or so all right so what's
happening how can I help you
so
um I'm in the later half of my life like
on the down slope how old are you
65. okay
so
so never in my whole life ever been
loved by anyone except my children
and I want to know if it's too late to
find that
hmm
what makes you think you've never been
loved
well it's not a started I know
do you know when you're left I'm
assuming because I have not ever thought
that except for my children no sometimes
your body uh doesn't tell you the truth
because it's too busy trying to protect
itself
sometimes our bodies do a great way of
pushing away people who are trying
desperately to love us because
maybe we loved our parents and that got
us abused or we loved our uncle and that
got us abused or we loved our parents
and one of them just took off on us
um and so our bodies put a GPS pin in
relationships as something scary that
gets you hurt and sometimes people try
to love us with all their might and all
they know how to do and our bodies push
them away
um did the the
or the is do your kids have the same dad
yes he never loved you
never
tell me about it yeah
so uh we met when we were 19 we married
at 20. we had five children we lost one
very early on it was our second son and
um and let me preface this by letting
you know he only married me because I
was pregnant okay and
um I believed when I said my vows that I
was there until death
um which pretty much did pretty much
kill me like emotionally
um to the point where I had to run and
I've been running ever since
running because you're scared he's gonna
get you and hurt you or running because
if you stop your body's gonna catch up
with you
running away from myself I think
I can't figure it out so can I tell you
what I just wrote down here a note that
I'm getting from your voice
sure I just wrote this down
your question is is it too late for
someone to love you
my question to you is
do you love you
what's so bad about Anne
everything I I'm calling bullcrap on
that it's not
that's not true
tell me what's so bad about Ian
thank you
when I had to run from my husband
I had nowhere to go with my children
and so
when I ran
I never got my token back
and they were my whole life I was a
I was a mom and a wife
for my whole adult life until that point
and he took everything for me and I have
been learning it with this
are you estranged from your kids
pretty much I mean we talk once in a
while I see them maybe once a year all
but one one has nothing to do with me
why not
he won't tell me what
okay
I was just with him
over a month ago and
um
we've spent about an hour together and
then
he had to go and he just he
he won't talk to me he won't
he says they're just it's just not
we were so close
we're so close and it's all gone
you were so close and there's been a
definite break I don't believe it's all
gone
okay I I don't believe that with all of
my heart
it's 25 years yep and I've tried
everything
I think there's one thing you haven't
tried
what's that okay
and before I say it
I want you to be open to this this one
um terrifying notion okay okay
can you be okay with this and I'm
nervous to even say it out loud because
you are somebody that takes negative
feedback as an identity
okay I want to be able to tell you
something and not have you instantly go
to yep there's more proof that I suck at
everything
okay
can we just two friends hang at two
friends from Texas just hanging out can
I just tell you
okay I want you to hold loosely
in your right or left hand I don't care
which one
the idea that maybe the way you've been
running
and trying to reconnect with your kids
isn't working can you hold that
absolutely okay so a few weeks ago I
tried to fix my mower
after a while it was clear what I'm
doing is not working
that doesn't mean I'm a bad dad it
doesn't mean I'm an idiot I'm stupid
whatever I just meant I'm not doing this
right I got to go to the internet and go
to the hive mind and figure it out okay
so similarly
you've tried a bunch of things
I want you to
think about this that son you just
mentioned
what if
every time you came around his body
started screaming at him to go
because if he loves you one more time
mom's gonna take off again we're not
gonna be able We're not gonna be able to
handle it this time
right I yes I agree with that okay so
and
what if nobody especially his scummy dad
never sit down when he was a teenager
becoming a young man
and taught him
how to have a challenging conversation
how to let your needs be met how to say
things out loud like I feel sad or I
miss you and nobody taught him how to do
that
and so now his body's got one tool one
strategy and that's avoidance that's it
and that avoidance is gonna kill him
but it keeps him alive it's like smoking
right It Gets You Through the next 10
minutes and over time it kills you it's
very similar so what I want to do is
enter into this space with your kids
very very submissively
and what I mean by that is there's no
explaining
no
hey you guys don't understand
it's very much taking a knee and saying
I'm your mom
and I miss you more than life itself
and I'd love to have you back in my life
when you'll have me
okay can I tell you something I've done
that you could tell me everything okay
tell me back tell me back
Okay so
um
I did that four years ago okay
I went to every one of them
and
I told them exactly that
um
I even moved across the country to be
near them
and nothing
nothing
happened it actually got worse or more
um the more I tried
that the more I felt like I was pushed
away
you know do you remember what I said
earlier
what I don't remember
I don't know what at some point your
kids bodies are probably trying to
protect them here here's where here's
let's get to all all the way down to the
bottom here carrying these regrets
around with you is somehow feeling you
feel protected by it what is carrying
all this regret doing for you
it's killing me exactly why don't you
set it down
I I don't know how
the guilt
the dot dot
that a mistress
um walked into their lives and took over
my life
thank you
and left me with nothing
and the way I watch my children suffer
because of that
it's like I can't forgive myself
do you want to
yeah
I want them to
that's not that's you can't control that
and if you come back seeking their
Desperately Seeking the
if you put the burden of your Wellness
on them
they're going to feel that a hundred
miles away and they have already decided
I can't carry mom's stuff anymore for
her
you've got to decide for Anne and no one
else
you may have 30 years left
okay oh I don't have that long you could
think all you want my grandmother didn't
either
well okay she kept even if I have even
even have 15 years that's fine
I'm going with 30. here's the deal you
have to decide for Anne
I want to not carry this stuff around
anymore yes I did some things in my life
that I regret and the only thing on
planet Earth I can do is control what
happens next
and every time that pass comes in here's
what I want you to do this is old school
I want you to take uh go to Home Depot
and get a couple of bricks
like paver bricks for like a dollar
maybe two bucks a match and I want you
to get some some some masking tape or
some duct tape and tape it on that brick
and I want you to write down a thing you
remember that you did to one kid or to
another kid or to another kid
okay and I want you to get four or five
of them
and I don't I don't to where it's
uncomfortable to carry them all at the
same time but don't oh don't hurt
yourself okay
okay and I want you to go in your
backyard
and I want you just to walk around your
backyard while carrying these things
and after a few minutes when your arms
start to get really heavy
and your hands start to get really raw
I want you to throw them in the back
corner of the yard
and say to yourself out loud I'm not
carrying this anymore
and I want you to stack those bricks up
in the corner and let them stay there
okay and every time you wake up you're
doing something you see some mom holding
her baby and your body rips you back 30
years to when you had to had to run for
your life
I want you to say out loud I'm not
carrying that anymore
I am loving me and I'm loving my family
moving forward
okay
I want you you're gonna have to practice
taking control of your thoughts and your
actions when's the last time you saw a
counselor
probably about 10 years ago okay the
time is right now
I'm worried about you okay I don't trust
anyone I trust no one there will be no
peace in your life unless you open up
your heart to trust somebody
and that's why I recommended a counselor
and not a friend because they are
restricted but through their code of
ethics she will lose her job or he will
lose his job and possibly have more
ramifications if they violate your
um
confidentiality
it's a safe place but you have to
practice being safe in a relationship
again because your body has said no more
Fair okay
yeah
do you trust me at least I'm just a dumb
podcast or whatever yeah actually um I
I
the two the two paths forward here is a
conscious decision every day I'm not
going to carry the past with me anymore
it's just dragging me down
it's not helping my current situation
and it's not helping my relationships
moving forward and I'm gonna go meet
with a counselor
because I need some new skills on
relationship building
and they're going to be a teacher it's
not a place for you to go to complain
and whine and all that that's not what
we're doing we're going to learn some
new skills and I want you to walk in the
door of a counselor and say these words
I need help learning to forgive myself
so that I can love recklessly and enjoy
the last 30 years of my life
okay okay
and you you'll show up to your kids to
the one or two that will meet with you
you will show up to them in a few months
as a ray of light
not as a something that like a dementor
that's trying to take something from
them
okay it will be something that is you're
providing light to the room you are it's
a whole new being
because Ann is finally
loving Anne
and you can't expect anybody in the
world to do something you're not willing
to do for yourself
correct
so I'm not going to ask my kids to
forgive me and love me until I love
myself and I forgive myself and one
can't be contingent on the other because
then it's not true forgiveness it's them
trying to prop mom up
it's crutches it's not a new sidewalk
okay
I don't know if there's enough time left
for me to forgive myself but I'll try
listen to me
you have to choose life
right now you're every morning you wake
up you get yourself on a one-way bus to
hell
because that's where you think you
belong
and that's not true
you don't belong in hell you belong
right next to me hanging out having
nachos in Texas
but only you and only you can decide not
to get on that bus every single morning
and beat yourself up and take yourself
to hell because that's where that's
where people like me go
yeah 30 years left
to start living
hang on the line I'm going to send you a
copy of my book own your past change
your future I want you to read it I'm
also going to send you a copy of
um see what else we got I'm going to
send you uh my friend Ken Coleman's book
proximity principle
that's going to help you think about
what you can do for work and career and
what I'm trying to do is get you into
maybe not start a new career but get you
into a place where you have purpose and
your value you got to go somewhere every
day you got to be around other people
you got to start saying hello and you
got to start saying I don't like that
and this is going to be about relational
practice it's a great
um read it's easy to read but it'll be
good for you okay and you've got to call
a professional therapist today
that's your promise to me okay I love
you Anne
choose life moving forward
choose it
we're rooting for you my sister we'll be
right back
hey good folks John deloney here I
I fell through a glitch in The Matrix
this is my job I get to have this show
do this show walk alongside each one of
you as a career this is what I do and I
have a blast doing it and me and the
team were so thankful for all of you for
being a part of our show whether you're
one of the original 17 or you're one of
the millions that's come since then we
are so grateful for you and we want to
put together the best possible show that
we can so if you're one of The Originals
or if you're brand new we want your
feedback tell us what you love about the
show what you hate about the show what
you'd like to see more of what you like
to hear more of and what you want us to
never do again you can email us at
askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's
askjohn ramseysolutions.com with your
feedback thank you for being such an
important part of the show rock on
all right let's go to Kayla
you got me on my knees Kayla in
Winchester what's up Kayla a guy picked
me up at a bar one time like that did it
work
uh I don't remember
probably
so that means yes
that means yes
that's fantastic sister what's up
um well my question is should I write my
mom's therapist a letter
ah tell me more
um
well I went no contact with her why this
past summer
I want it off the train I don't know how
else to put it sorry no today we're
don't be sorry at all sometimes we all
are going off the rails on the crazy
train good for you
um
she has a really traumatic past okay
and would remind you of that constantly
and she finally did reach out and get
help and I was really proud of her for
that
um but she just kept disrespecting that
I wanted to go no contact with her I was
just done
um how is she disrespecting you give me
an example
well
we got to a point in our relationship
where like I said I wanted off the crazy
train just couldn't do it anymore what
does that mean tell me give me some
specifics
I'm getting really specific so I asked
too much of her and really my father at
the same time so
um my husband and I were living in a
house that was too small for our family
and we decided to get with my parents
um for them to let us build a house on
property that they were going to give to
us like they did for my older brother
and they have a pretty big piece of land
so we paid for the survey the land was
deeded over to us my dad is a general
contractor he was supposed to be helping
us build a house
well tumultuous situation after
tumultuous situation we actually moved
in with them because we sold our house
and was living in their four-bedroom
Farmhouse we kind of had our own space
um they tried really hard I guess not to
crimp our style and vice versa but my
mom just kept spinning out
she
um flew off the handle because she was
missing a notebook one day and she
thought I had this notebook like it's
always been
um
just something small that just sets her
off and I mean she goes she goes off the
wall about things and it she would spin
out and it would just remind me of my
childhood where her and my father would
just fight constantly and that's how I
grew up okay so so hold on why
do you still live in her house
no they kicked us out after a month okay
they actually told us to get the F out
okay so y'all got the F out and you got
a new place you and your husband
yes okay so why the no contact order why
don't you just block her on your phone
and go about your day go about your life
all right did you get your money back
for the house mess
um we timing of it was really
[Music]
was all said and done the property is so
deeded to us and we just sell it we
don't know what to do with it so
ah my husband doesn't feel like it's
appropriate to do that
well
that's between y'all too
right you want to put your daughter in
this crazy mess no no no she's only
three but we think in our minds my
husband Minds that that's going to be
her property one day why in the world
would you want another one of your
family members to go back to that chaos
I know it Luke is sort of crazy well
sell it go about your life move
it's a crazy thing about America you can
live wherever you want to do whatever
you want
there's something about this situation
where you are choosing
misery
like like
no let me say it this way I don't think
you choose a misery
I think you've heard me say probably if
you ever listen to this show choose
guilt over resentment
I think you chose guilt the right thing
to do
and I think it's killing you
yeah because I have all these outside
factors be like you only have one set of
parents you need to work it out with
them I'm and I tell these people no
Kayla Kayla
out none of those people get a vote
your mom and your dad have proven
themselves to be unsafe people to be
around
and every time you listen to another
voice you're deciding yeah I'm just
gonna go get my head kicked in for a few
minutes
and I for one I don't practice MMA
anymore I haven't in a long time so I
don't choose to get my head kicked on a
regular basis anymore
you shouldn't either
they don't get a vote
I mean I'm trying to set up boundaries
you know I told them to give me time
after all of that that was just a
terrible situation instead of put my
family in
and she came back and this was verbatim
your dad is very upset about this and if
we're not worthy to be a part of your
family we want our families laying back
because I don't know what to do he cries
all the time this is very sad he doesn't
have many years left and you're stealing
more like placing all the guilt on me
about this entire situation she's been
around and told people that I'm the one
with the problem Kayla Kayla Kayla Kayla
Kayla
you've heard the old the old wives tale
about the uh the rattlesnake in the
paper bag
you ever heard that
yeah
so there was a guy who had a
it's all rattlesnake on the ground and
he picked it up and scooped it into a
plastic bag with a paper bag and
the rattlesnake said hey thanks man I
really appreciate you
um
I'd like it love it if you I got an itch
in the back of my head I can't scratch
it I'd love it if you scratched that
itch for me the guy's like sure man
and he reached in the bag to scratch
that itch and the rattlesnake bit him
and he's like what do you why'd you do
that and he's like well I'm a
rattlesnake that's what I do
and a guy's like that was the meanest
thing I was just kind to you and
whatever he's like I know I'm around
saying this is what I do
and then
a little while later the rattlesnake's
like hey man I'm sorry that was that's
100 on me my bad I need to overcome that
um but I still get that crazy itch we
please get it and the guy's like no last
time you bit me and he's like I know I
know anyway he reached in to scratch him
again and it bites him again he goes I
told you I'm a rattlesnakes what'd I do
and at that point
the second byte on is that guy's fault
because he keeps putting his hand back
in the bag
your mom is clearly demonstrated that
she does not want to be in relationship
with you
she wants you as a proxy to make her
husband feel less crappy because she
can't do it
she wants you in their life so that they
have a punching bag other than each
other
but she doesn't want a relationship with
you a loving mother-daughter
relationship and I hate that for you
because that's one of the most precious
relationships in the world well it's
never been there right why are you
continuing why are you continuing to
scream and fight for it because she
you
gave me no I don't know what that is
I thought you said you gave her no con
oh you went no contact you just blocked
her you haven't called the police and
say I want a no contact order filed on
this woman
no I never did that okay you can do that
and make it illegal for her to come to
your house or to contact you
if she refuses to accept your boundaries
you can go one step further
and there's nothing in her the way she's
she's acted towards you that would make
me think that she's one day gonna get it
that's right
and I mean
to go to invite me to another therapy
appointment which would be sitting down
next to her with her therapist which
just seems insane
she actually was level-headed talking to
me she was still saying the same things
but she was level at least level-headed
and she didn't seem high and I was like
well maybe there is some hope in this
but she still was saying the same thing
blaming other people for her actions
she's she just doesn't take any
accountability Kayla you've
you've gotta
I know it's frustrating I can't even
imagine
and I know it's heartbreaking I can't
even imagine
but every time she shows up you sound
surprised
and every time she shows up your body's
experiencing this as though it's
happened it happened the first time oh
yeah if I just kick off yeah
so until you can be safe your body will
chill out around her you gotta create
space
and that might mean you talk this over
with your husband but that might mean
you let her know
I've asked you repeatedly for some space
for you to stop showing up at my house
for you to stop calling me and blaming
at me for everything going on in your
home
I'm happy to sell you this land back
or if quite honestly if it was me I
would probably dust my hands off and
give them the stupid land back and
because they have clearly made it the
dirt is more important than you
I'll repeat that that dirt is more
important than you in Your gran in their
grandkid your kid and your husband
here's the dirt back bye
my life is too short
feel how you feel right now
at this point forward
you're choosing to put your hand back in
the bag and get bit over and over and
over again
I would make One Last Stand and say if
you come again I'm going to contact the
police I'm going to file a no contact
order
I don't want you on my property I don't
want you calling me I don't want you to
connecting with me at this time I will
reach back out to you when I feel ready
and answer your original question yes
um
her counselor if she's has any ethics at
all cannot even tell you that she's
seeing her as a client can't even
acknowledge that this person is a
counselor I mean a client of mine but
she can
um receive information and data from
outside sources so absolutely I think
it'd be great to send a letter
I think this stuff's always healthy
that'd be wonderful don't expect any
sort of return from the therapist the
therapist would you should file this
therapist should lose their license if
she writes you back is what I'm saying
other than to say I've received your
note thank you anything beyond that like
oh this is for your mom that's great
but yeah send it send it
and ask yourself this question
[Music]
how long
am I gonna avoid the hard part which is
grieving the fact that my mom is
choosing these other things over me
and instead of choosing That season of
grief that you're gonna have to go
through one way or another
you're choosing to get bit over and over
and over again
this sounds crazy choose grief
choose heartbreak for a season
because on the other side of grief on
the other side of heartbreak
that Kayla's where healing is
we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show I'm
actually recording this on Valentine's
Day
none of these calls were Valentine's Day
calls for sure but
in an effort to give Kelly what she
wants
this is what is what was this song
this was like is you and Robert dance to
this song yeah it's just how we dance to
at our wedding
um I know I can see you glowing in there
this is
this is the song Kelly and her husband
Robert danced to on their wedding
ooh it's called you and I we can conquer
the world and it goes like this here we
are on earth together it's you and I
God has made us fall in love it's true
that's mean you have to fall in love
with Kelly
I've really Found Someone Like You
would stay the love you will stay the
love you feel for me will it say
that you will be by my side to see me
through until my life is through well in
my mind we can conquer the world and
love you and I you and I Kelly and
Robert you and I
love you guys we'll see you soon